[Música]
y qué buena manera de empezar revista de
prensa en directo américa con la música
de queens que tanto le gusta también a
mi compañera rosa pérez masdéu rosa
bienvenida feliz miércoles
lamentablemente 30 años de la partida
pero sigue vivo sin duda a frei mercury
le gustaba no rosa me encanta la verdad
es mágica no lo que nos genera esta
música este fin de semana podemos ir a
bailar a freddie mercury para celebrar
que todavía sigue viva su música vamos a
hablar ahora en la primera parte de
revista de prensa el quinto aniversario
de la firma definitiva de los acuerdos
de paz entre la extinta guerrilla de las
farc también del gobierno de colombia
empezamos con el tiempo que titula cinco
años después la paz con las farc aún no
se sienten en las regiones este artículo
lo hizo el periodista jon torres rosa
buenos días exacto pues el periodista
john torres coordinó un gran grupo de
periodistas que hizo un repaso de cuál
es la situación cinco años después de la
firma de estos acuerdos y el resumen
serían los crímenes de ex combatientes y
la ocupación de zonas donde estaban las
farc por otros grupos armados
son dos puntos críticos pero se destacan
importantes avances
este texto hace un repaso de la historia
de cómo se fraguaron los acuerdos desde
los primeros acercamientos entre las
partes hasta el nuevo en el plebiscito
la renegociación de los acuerdos y
finalmente la firma de la que hoy se
cumplen cinco años no y dice que pues
tras esta media década los resultados
son dispares en dos distintos frentes
creo que hay una coincidencia no y es la
seguridad tanto de los desmovilizados
entre los que se han contado 300
asesinados desde 2016 como de los
habitantes en los lugares donde las farc
fueron fuertes sigue siendo pues el
mayor desafío también han destaca este
gran artículo la importancia de la web
de la jurisdicción especial para la paz
y también vemos aquí un mapa con datos
de indepaz que señala la presencia de
los distintos grupos armados que
persisten al
2021 todavía en el país entre los cuales
destaca pues disidencias de la extinta
de guerrilla por otro lado grupos
también de ln y también lo que califica
como grupos de narcoparamilitares y un
último dato que nos da este artículo es
que según los datos del centro de
recursos para el análisis de conflicto
los acuerdos habrían salvado entre 4200
y 6 mil 300 vidas bueno los acuerdos que
todavía no están bien implementados con
muchas deficiencias seguimos con el
tiempo que lleva en la portada una
entrevista de los periodistas juan
sebastián longo y javier gonzález
penagos al presidente santos no pudieron
hacer trizas el acuerdo aunque lo que
hicieron perdón es rosa vamos con el
espectador exacto vamos a llevar esta
esta entrevista en portada el espectador
porque recordemos que santos es el ex
presidente no que acabó firmando los
acuerdos con rodrigo londoño más
conocido como timochenko y bien le
preguntan cuál es el balance a los cinco
años de esta firma tan difícil y lo que
enlace es un balance positivo y dice que
bueno es
un logro respecto a otros acuerdos de
paz firmados en el mundo pero le
preguntan y que faltan para el
cumplimiento de estos acuerdos tal y
como fueron redactados y el insiste de
nuevo en el tema de la seguridad dice lo
más grave es la parte de la seguridad
los los asesinatos de los ex
combatientes y la seguridad de los
líderes sociales un punto fundamental
que de una u otra forma tiene que ver
con la implementación de los acuerdos y
reconoce ahí el estado ha fallado
también señala como una carencia la no
implementación de la reforma rural o el
retroceso en la sustitución de los
cultivos y le preguntan a qué espera del
gobierno que va a surgir electo de las
presidenciales del año que viene y él
asegura que cualquier ejecutivo va a
estar comprometido con el proceso de paz
y también han recalca el papel
fundamental de la comunidad
internacional rosa destacamos ahora una
explicación de la silla vacía en twitter
sobre el hecho de que eeuu vaya a
retirar a las farc de su lista de
organizaciones terroristas exacto la
silla vacía este medio colombiano
también hace un y lo de twiter
explicativo en el que destaca pues que
eeuu se ha sumado a lo que la unión
europea hizo en 2017 y es retirar a esta
extinta guerrilla de la lista de
organizaciones terroristas y explica que
lo que implica estar en esta lista
estadounidense de grupos terroristas es
que se convierte en ilegal que cualquier
persona empresa u organización pues éste
te dé recursos o financiamiento así es
rosa vamos ahora a ver un reportaje
sobre la vida en la paz una pieza de
santiago turrado del país los hijos del
baby boom de las farc crecen en paz
quieres el baby boom rosa pues a través
de una crónica en los que es en lo que
se llama tcr que son estos espacios
territoriales de capacitación y
reincorporación donde viven muchos ex
guerrilleros el periodista hace una
crónica de lo que es la vida atrás a los
acuerdos de paz y este baby boom no está
explosión demográfica entre las filas de
los ex guerrilleros una vez en 2016 se
llegó a la paz con el estado y de hecho
explica un poco lo que es la vida en la
comunidad a través del cumpleaños de
dylan que es uno de estos niños
perteneciente al baby boom cuya madre
era un ex pero es de hecho una ex
guerrillera que explica cómo fue
obligada a abortar cuando estaba en el
monte en la guerrilla y básicamente
también el periodista recoge distintos
testigos que explican que los hijos en
muchos casos son un motor de ilusión
para seguir adelante con la
implementación del acuerdo así es rosa y
recordemos que hoy entonces se cumplen
estos cinco años de la implementación
del acuerdo de paz luego de que el 26 de
septiembre se firmara y se hiciera este
gran acto en la ciudad de cartagena en
colombia luego el plebiscito recordemos
donde los colombianos decidían si si
aceptaban este acuerdo o no ganó el
acuerdo el no y luego tuvieron esos dos
meses para renegociar este acuerdo y fue
entonces el 24 de noviembre hace 5 años
que finalmente se firmó este acuerdo que
fue ratificado
por el puesto de la cámara de
representantes y también el senado
colombiano ahora rosa vamos a cerrar
esta revista de prensa con los 30 años
de la muerte de freddie mercury que
hablábamos al principio además aprovechó
para invitarlos a ustedes televidentes a
que en la cuenta de nuestro canal en
twitter nos diga cuál es su canción
favorita de cuina y les vamos a estar
leyendo rosa pero vamos entonces a
hablar de freddie mercury mira hemos
hecho una pequeñísima selección porque
hoy freddie mercury hallen a los
titulares alrededor del mundo por un
lado hemos escogido de conversación que
es este medio académico donde discuten
pues personas de la academia de
distintos ámbitos de conocimiento y
destaca ya hace 30 años de que desde la
muerte de freddie mercury y su música
sigue siendo la banda sonora de nuestras
vidas y destacan a su importantísimo
papel a la hora de romper las fronteras
del mainstream y de lo establecido tanto
a nivel de composición como en tanto que
cantante tanto que persona de la
performance o influencia en el legado
que vino después de él por otro lado
clarín este medio argentino destaca así
anunció que tenía sida porque recordemos
esto en un periodo de máxima de
estigmatización de esta enfermedad de
hecho el anuncio fue hecho por parte de
su representante y al día siguiente se
produjo la muerte del cantante y ya para
terminar página 12 dice 330 años de la
muerte de freddie mercury esa fuerza de
la naturaleza ya podríamos decir que su
música la música de queen ya forma parte
de la historia de la humanidad no raúl
cuál es su canción favorita de twin rosa
yo diría want to break free ok la mía es
radio haga me encanta esa canción rosa
muchísimas gracias me encanta además
terminar revista de prensa hablando de
música cultura y por supuesto del gran
freddie mercury rosa nos vemos mañana
con más revista de prensa ahora vamos a
nuestro reportaje del día